I am here with the david dobrik okay
YouTube personality david dobrik i
already feel better about myself just
standing next to you okay so these
questions are very very simple quite
simple great thank you
we are here tonight celebrating kids
what was the best part about being a kid
honestly I'm getting away with a lot of
things like getting in trouble and not
like you know not being like seriously
punished for it that was the best what
about you what's your favorite part of
being a kid it's kind of like the
freedom just like wherever you want but
and you can you can fail test and like
yeah it's like ah you messed up but who
cares always another day yeah whoo
what's your celebrity idol growing up
and did you ever get to meet them my
celebrity idol growing up oh I don't
think I don't think I really had one I
don't know who I don't know maybe maybe
Ryan Reynolds but I know I've never
gotten to meet them hmm
okay cool next question the Kids Choice
Awards is all about slime are you
prepared to get slime yeah that's why
I'm here
I'm not I'm not here for the award show
I just heard there was a bucket of slime
and I'm coming to consume it oh yeah I
think one year they disguised the blimp
as like it they disguised it as a blimp
but it was actually a slime cannon so
they just I'm on the lookout your mic
can be a slime cannon oh yeah I'm gonna
stay far away I don't know your video
was surprised so many fans Rick Kylie
Jenner it was like amazing okay what was
the best part about meeting all those
fans with Kylie oh it was it was so
great to like to have people meet Kylie
and like realize like how much of a
normal and cool person she is like
that's the coolest part is like when
someone meets a celebrity they're like
oh wow like this person is literally
just like me and it was like it was
really fun to see like like a super
laid-back version of Kylie that's kind
of how I feel about you but you have
worked on so many videos with
celebrities who's one person that you
wish to work with um Chris Pratt yeah
have you seen him yet no he's gonna be
how are you doing this when you're ten I
don't know what I was doing when I was
ten but it definitely wasn't on orange
carpet good job I'm proud of you
yeah thank you so much thank you